Guy Bedos 25 ans de carrière il a 49 ans
on le dirait pas 25 ans qu'il dit style
des sketchs acidulés qui le regardent le
monde de la rue et les grandes ce monde
c'est du spectacle quotidien qu'offre
l'actualité qu'il tire la force la
drôlerie parfois la méchanceté de son
spectacle il est de gauche et ne s'en
cache pas mais il n'aime pas la gauche
quand elle ressemble à la droite il se
dit heureux j'ai lu ça dans une
interview alors Guy Bedos vous êtes
comme tous les Français vous baignez
dans le bonheur
peut-être pas exagéré
comme
ce que je suis c'est à dire un artiste
qui cherche à faire rire et à donner du
bonheur tout du moins pendant 2h30 mais
je crois que
les gens qui viennent me voir sont pas
finalement heureux tout le temps ils
sont peut-être heureux j'espère en tout
cas majorité de ceux qui viennent ont
l'air d'être heureux avec moi mais
peut-être parce que justement je leur
parle pas que de choses les méfiantes et
niaise c'est le bonheur lucide c'est le
bonheur dans la dans la liberté de
parole dans la et dans la vérité ce que
je voulais dire c'est qu'à longueur de
journée on entend des gens qui disent ça
va pas on n'est pas bien il y a pas
d'argent c'est la crise et boum un
sondage sur le bonheur et c'est étonnant
les chiffres mais j'ai envie de citer je
vais faire le pédant deux secondes une
phrase de un renard disait ce n'est pas
le tout d'être heureux encore faut-il
être sûr que les autres sont malheureux
et il semblerait que les gens sont
persuadés que les autres sont malheureux
ce qui est vrai c'est que comment dire
il y a une il y a une conscience que les
choses vont mal vont aller mal peuvent
aller très mal il y a quand même
ce qui peut être sur sur la sensibilité
des gens la guerre on en entend parler
il y a vous là qui nous donnez des
nouvelles absolument consternantes donc
il y a effectivement je pense sociologue
mais il y a un repliement sur sur ce
qu'on peut contrôler c'est à dire sa
propre vie dans le meilleur des cas son
métier sa famille bien sûr et les choses
sur lesquelles on a vraiment un impact
je peux parler même en mon propre nom
c'est vrai que je suis pas vraiment
malheureux dans ma vie alors pour
retrouver un peu le sourire on peut
revenir au thème que vous développez
dans votre spectacle vous dites ça
devient difficile d'être de gauche
surtout quand on est pas de droite
qu'est-ce que vous entendez par là c'est
une boutade ça veut pouvoir ça veut
vouloir dire des tas de choses je sais
que
vous l'avez vu hier le spectacle hier
soir il y a aussi que je suis un peu
comme un
ivrogne à qui faut répéter ce qu'il a
dit la veille monsieur le lendemain je
crois que j'improvise profonde
c'est un peu profond mais j'ai pas
vraiment envie de sous-titrer vous voyez
parce que attention à justement au
sérieux dès qu'il s'agit d'humour à
cette heure là et sans sans un élément
qui est capital à savoir le public et la
complicité avec le public la marade avec
les autres ben je suis comme un chanteur
qui n'aurait pas son orchestre quoi
est-ce que est-ce que vous êtes comme
votre copain montant à l'issue du
socialisme
en tout cas il a beaucoup dit ces
derniers temps
je parle un petit peu voilà vous êtes en
train d'essayer de me piéger sur mon
temps pas du tout je vais avoir votre
avis parce que je parle de un petit peu
de mon temps sur scène parce que
justement je fais une revue de presse et
que mon temps était dans l'actualité
donc c'était comme on dit maintenant
incontournable je pouvais pas ne pas
parler longtemps on va dire que mon
temps c'est ma Signoret quelque chose se
font partie de ma famille
j'ai signé beaucoup de petits chiens
avec eux etc il se trouve que bon là
c'est aussi il y a eu un petit dérapage
de livres à propos de d'une certaine
appel
contre le racisme et l'extrême droite à
Dreux et bon j'ai eu l'impression que
c'était un peu trompé de pétition et qui
et qu'il avait envie de parler d'autre
chose alors que le sujet c'était Dreux
et l'extrême droite à Dreux mais vous
vous n'êtes pas vous n'êtes pas oui mais
vous n'êtes pas prêt comme lui à
critiquer aussi fondamentalement la
gauche
je veux aller exactement
jusqu'où je veux aller c'est à dire que
je veux critiquer la gauche je veux être
libre je crois que c'est ce que les gens
aiment bien chez moi y compris les gens
de gauche y compris les gens de gauche
qui sont maintenant au pouvoir je crois
c'est très sain de pouvoir critiquer
mais je n'ai pas envie
de
me créer des nouveaux supporters
oui je comprends mais dans votre
spectacle vous n'êtes pas très méchant
pour le gouvernement ni pour les
difficultés actuelles alors bon d'accord
vous avez quelques personnes que vous
avez moins que d'autres Max Gallo il
déguste de faire aussi enfin de manière
générale quand même vous êtes
à ce gentil je peux pas effectivement
j'ai passé de ma vie et vous avez dit
mon âge ça fait très longtemps que que
j'attends la gauche alors je vais pas
travailler pour Chirac Giscard bar et
les autres forcément je
je veux effectivement continuer à dire
des choses et par fonction un type comme
moi ne peut pas être du côté du manche
donc je ne serai jamais effectivement
que les Max Gallo écrivain qui devient
soit qui se coupe les cheveux et qui se
met des costumes bien coupés et qui
vient nous dire ce qu'a dit Mitterrand
Mitterrand crash une olive et Gallo a
fait une salade niçoise bon moi je veux
bien mais
il est un peu énervant c'est tout hein
c'était un très bon équipement du temps
Jacques Médecin oui de faire vous avez
dit aussi de faire ces plein de choses
sur Chirac mais Chirac en séparé sur de
faire c'est celui qu'il dit le premier
qui est oui c'était je disais ça c'est
drôle non mais dis par vous c'est moins
bien
de travail est-ce que vous êtes aussi
anticommuniste que mon temps
je le suis je suis surtout
antisoviétique
très très nettement
je suis pas mais je n'irai pas
au point où mon temps est allé dire que
par exemple la Dreux puisque je reviens
sur Dreux c'est ça qui a Camille fait au
poudre pour mon temps je pense pas que
pour les immigrés de Dreux
la menace imminente ça soit l'Armée
rouge voyez je pense que c'est pas
exactement c'était pas tout à fait le
sujet une dernière question hier dans
votre spectacle il y avait
une entreprise
soviétique qui était là oui vous l'avez
vu oui j'aime mieux être interviewé par
lui à Paris qui être interrogé par lui à
Moscou
on en termine là-dessus merci et bonne
chance
ça va très bien je suis content je suis
heureux